Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update and it is official a sequel the
titanfall is in the works titanfall was
a successful debut title for developer
respawn so a sequel should come as no
surprise confirmation of the project has
come from respawn co-founder Vince
Zampella who said in an interview with
IGN I guess EA announced the sequel so i
could play coy and pretend i don't know
anything about it or yeah so we're
working on a sequel to be clear EA has
previously hinted at plans for sequel
but this is the first official
confirmation from the game's developer
he went on to say that the game has no
official name yet but quote we're
working on that he added that titanfall
2 was the main focus at the studio and
confirmed that it would be a quote
multi-platform project they suggest that
the game could be coming to PlayStation
4 as well as xbox one and pc he also
hinted at a second smaller secret
project underway at the studio he said
we're starting up a second team and
doing some smaller stuff two small
exploratory taking it slow as for the
name for the sequel I mean titanfall 2
seems like a no-brainer but what if he
got weird with it like some taken three
kind of tootin fall with the number I'd
be kind of cool and terrible suggest
you're cool and terrible ideas in the
comments below and for more news go to
gamespot com / news
you